there is now surveillance video in the
case of a mentally ill man who
suffocated to death while in police
custody a warning it is disturbing this
is The Man Who Lost His Life 28 year old
Ivo otieno the video shows officers and
staff pressing their weight on otieno as
he was checked into a mental hospital
defense attorneys tried to stop any
release of the footage which was
obtained by The Washington Post 10
people have now been charged with murder
Jeff begaze has more
the video which is silent shows Ivo
otieno handcuffed and in leg irons being
brought into the Virginia Hospital's
admission room by Henrico County
sheriff's deputies on March 6. they walk
into a chair about eight minutes later
at least two officers are seen Holding
otno On The Ground they seem to react
when he moves the officers then appear
to lose their grip on otno and they
rolled him across the floor
four minutes later additional officers
and Hospital staff joined to restrain
them soon thereafter at least nine
people are seen piling on top of otiano
to hold him down with other Hospital
staff observing what's happening
otieno's mother was shown the video last
week
my son was treated like a dog worse than
a dog my son was tortured according to
the video
otieno was held down for about 11
minutes
you see him being
restrained so brutally
with
knee on his neck 20 minutes after
entering the admissions room
otiano appears to be immobile Washington
Post says resuscitation efforts lasted
less than an hour
died at the scene Seven sheriff's
deputies and three Hospital workers have
been charged with second-degree murder
and the prosecutor says additional
charges and arrest are pending
for CBS mornings I'm Jeff begaze
you were right well that video is very
tough to watch and it's interesting to
see the hospital people standing I wish
we could hear audio to see did anybody
say hey
please stop yeah and he's already uh
he's in shackle arm iron so I don't know
why the the the huge amount of force
there all those individuals on top of
them I I really do wish we had audio and
there's going to be a lot of questions
we'll learn more definitely that story
is not over